inside every cell of your body
billions of tiny machines are hard at
work
they carry oxygen in your blood let your
eyes detect light
and even make your muscles move these
machines are proteins
and they underpin every biological
process in every living thing
each protein has an intricate 3d shape
that defines what it does and how it
works
we know of over 200 million proteins and
counting
but we only know the exact 3d shapes of
a fraction of these
unravel a protein and you'll see it's
like a string of beads
made up of 20 different types of amino
acids interactions between these amino
acids
make the protein fold as it finds its
shape out of almost limitless
possibilities
for decades a community of scientists
have been working on a way to figure out
a protein shake
just from its string of amino acids this
is a major challenge
in our understanding of biology so we
created an
ai system to solve this problem called
alpha fold
it's trained on the sequences and
structures of about a hundred thousand
proteins
painstakingly mapped out by scientists
around the world
today it can accurately predict a
protein shape
just from its sequence of amino acids
alpha fold's predictions could enable
progress in all sorts of areas
imagine a future where we can understand
diseases more quickly
and develop drugs to fight them or one
where we could use
enzymes to break down plastic waste or
even to capture carbon from the
atmosphere
or with the help of proteins
there's a lot more work to be done but
unlocking the shapes of these building
blocks
could help scientists better understand
the natural world
and perhaps expand our knowledge of life
itself